houston police officially launching a
criminal probe into the after world
chaos that left eight people dead and
hospitalized dozens more police also
confirming reports that some of the
victims may have been injected with
drugs by a needle with a security guard
among those possibly pricked
of a security officer he was reaching
over to
restrain or grab a citizen and he felt a
prick in his neck and the medical staff
did notice a prick that was similar to
a prick that you would get if somebody's
trying to inject
rapper travis scott says he's devastated
about what happened while he was
performing
i'm honestly just devastated and
i could never imagine anything like this
just
happening we've been working closely
with everyone to just try to get to the
bottom of this
it's worth noting this isn't the first
time the grammy-nominated rapper has
been in trouble with the law on two
separate occasions in 2015 and 2018
scott pleaded guilty to misdemeanor
charges of reckless conduct after
telling fans to jump barricades rush the
stage and bypass security during
concerts in both chicago and arkansas
abby i want to come to you first
and get back to what originated as a
rumor but the idea that people were
feeling syringe jabs coming out of
nowhere
i can't imagine um again our hearts and
prayers go out to the families of
everyone who died because to think that
you're going to a concert it's an
innocent thing you're going to have fun
and there's someone potentially pricking
other people in the neck and injecting
them with drugs i i just
i i'm speechless thinking about it and
actually um some of the names of the
victims were released in their photos
john hilgert 14 years old brianna
rodriguez 16 franco patino 21 rudy pena
23 and then when you hear about travis
scott and the fact that he's encouraged
this type of behavior before and he's
actually been sued and arrested for it
and hasn't learned his lesson i hope
that other artists are seeing this and
they're encouraged to not um you know
encourage this type of behavior for lack
of better word at their concerts as well
and charlie we are just learning that
the first lawsuit in this case has now
been filed on behalf of one of the
victims
it seeks 1 million dollars it is against
travis scott live nation which is the
organizer and drake the performer who at
one point was also on stage with travis
scott i think this is just going to be
the beginning
yeah you know when we talked about this
last night um you know all we could
really say is my goodness how terrible
how tragic you know our hearts went out
to the families but uh but you know as
new information comes out uh you start
to wonder what the hell is going on in
this place and uh you you know and you
know you you always want to try to find
some sort of reason some sort of
explanation for why something happened
uh especially if it's senseless you you
you people it's a human nature to sort
of grasp for explanations well it's
something like this it's you often don't
find explanations but if in fact this
guy travis scott who has a record of
trying to encourage his fans to rush the
stage
if in fact and all the videotape will be
gone through all of the footage of
people you know instagramming and doing
stuff from there off of their phones
it's all going to be looked through if
in fact he did that again he should be
locked up and he should be he should be
sued for for millions of dollars he
should be sued out of existence if he
did this this concept that that there
aren't consequences for the things you
do and the things you say especially in
a in a crowded uh boisterous
environment like this it really is uh
it's it's shocking beyond words
and and joe this we're just learning of
this lawsuit the investigation is still
underway we don't know who's going to be
held liable here however in the lawsuit
they call this predictable that this was
predictable and the fact that this has
happened in the past
i just wonder i mean his fa even if
travis scott
didn't encourage people in this moment
to rush the stage if his fans know that
he has done that in the past i'm
wondering if that could come into play
here exactly
that's a great great question and look
you look at precedent in these
situations alicia right and you look at
a guy named paul wertheimer and he led
an investigation of a 1979 concert crush
that killed 11 people i believe it was
in cincinnati and he says that houston
authorities here did not do enough to
keep the crowds safe let me quote him
quote the crowd in houston never should
have gotten that big and dense it was a
preventable tragedy that happened
because safety precautions were ignored
and because there are millions of
dollars here to be made unquote that
about wraps it up yeah
yeah and abby you know i think there's
going to be a question now i think there
that's going to have to be addressed is
how do you handle crowd size at these
festivals right what 50 000 people in
attendance at this festival when you're
talking about general admission um you
kind of assume you know one person goes
a lot of other people are going to go as
well
yeah i mean i think that's exactly it i
don't really know if you can control a
crowd of that size so i think it would
have to come from the organizers of not
selling as many tickets of course they
will lose money but that money is worth
it to you know spare someone's life and
i listen to someone else talk about this
also they said maybe have have some
assigned seating and not allow a mosh
pit type of situation like this there
are certain things that can be done and
you know i do think that there there was
a lot of law enforcement from what i
read there again i said this yesterday
but the houston mayor said there was
more security at this event than there
was at the world series of course you
know there are 50 000 plus people at
this but yeah i think alicia you hit on
the head i don't really know if you can
control 50 000 people that's nearly
impossible i can imagine well we will
continue to watch this hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else